this is a tease made and it is the most
British invention it's a combination
alarm clock and electric kettle which
means that it has two settings alarm an
alarm with tea unlike a lot of clocks
that have built into appliances so
clocks on ovens and microwaves and
old-style clock radios and central
heating systems this clock keeps time by
using the frequency of the power grid
that it's connected to or would be
connected to anyway obviously I don't
have power out here power grids on this
side Atlantic run at a frequency of 50
Hertz 50 cycles a second
now that 50 Hertz frequency might rise
or fall by a tiny fraction a
supply-and-demand affect the grid but
over the course of days and weeks the
electricity companies guarantee that
it'll be averaged out to 50 Hertz so
plots like this which have to be plugged
into the grid anyway can use that
regular 50 cycles a second beat to keep
themselves accurate set this to the
correct time and it'll keep the correct
time as long as the powers on except
over the last month clocks over in
Europe have lost 6 minutes if they're
connected to the continental European
power system which is one connected
synchronized grid stretching all the way
from Spain to Denmark to Turkey if that
clock is connected to that grid it's 6
minutes slow this was revealed with
press release a couple of days ago from
the European transmission operators
Association who managed to write a press
release that sounded vaguely like angry
parent who was getting close to the end
of their rope the problem is politics
Serbia and Kosovo have fallen out with
each other that is an enormous
simplification if you think I'm gonna
try and explain the history of the
Balkan politic system while all your
teas made you are sorely mistaken
Kosovo is low on power Serbia isn't
helping manage it and as a result the
entire European grid has been slightly
underpowered since the middle of January
not by much
but enough that the average grid
frequency has dropped from 50 Hertz to
49.99 6
so clocks like this who are expecting 50
ok it doesn't sound like much but it
works out to them losing 6 minutes over
the last couple of months problem number
one is getting the grid back up to
frequency and hopefully politics will
solve that but problem number two is
well it is fixed should the european
authorities bring the grid back to 50 or
should they run it slightly fast for a
few weeks if they do it'll bring
everything back that wasn't manually
corrected but anyone who has already
changed their clocks will then find them
starting to run six minutes fast and
they'll have to change them again
they're probably gonna pick the second
option but who knows Vanja tea for me I
don't have to worry about it as I'm sure
52 percent of Britons will be ecstatic
to hear the mainland European grid is
not synchronized to the British national
grid here it is connected through two
undersea cables one under the English
Channel from France and the other one
from the Netherlands landing right here
on the Isle of grain which is near
nowhere it's it's it's it's absolutely
in the middle of nowhere but these
cables are direct current cables not
alternating current they don't require
grid synchronization so while mainland
Europe's grid is slow our British grid
is going at 50 British cycles a second
as Her Majesty intended our ovens are
turning on at the right time our clock
radios are remaining on time our our
microwaves are showing the correct time
all old they're showing 12 o'clock
because no one's bothered to program
them but that's not the point the point
is that the clocks may be going slow all
over Europe but here in Britain our teas
maids
are boiling precisely on schedule god
save the queen and god help us all
good I think that's it take
you